cuando llegó al poder en 1999 abdelaziz
buteflika hizo renacer la esperanza en
el seno de la población argelina el país
se tambaleaba después de cerca de una
década de guerra civil producto de la
violencia entre islamistas y la fuerza
de seguridad que se cobró 150 mil vidas
candidatos del ejército y el único en la
carrera luego de la retirada de sus
adversarios quienes denunciaron un
supuesto fraude el día previo al
escrutinio se hizo con las riendas de un
país desgarrado por la guerra llegó el
momento de detener la división de acabar
con los costos la mayoría del pueblo
argelino de todos los sudaneses y todo
tipo de sensibilidad que tiene la
suficiente capacidad de entender todo el
mal que se le ha hecho a nuestro país
anoche el presidente argelino se
presentaba como un constructor de la paz
en 2004 fue reelegido y siguió con su
objetivo de la pacificación pidiendo
perdón a los islamistas que seguían en
la clandestinidad una elección política
que denunciaron su opositor es abdelaziz
buteflika cultivó su imagen de garante
de la estabilidad junto con sus
homólogos extranjeros y para quedarse en
el poder modificó la constitución lo que
le permitió buscar tercer mandato
encontró poca resistencia en un país
todavía paralizado por el recuerdo de
sus años del plomo nuevamente reelegido
sus opositores alertaron de la
confiscación del poder por parte del
jefe de estado víctima donde rama
cerebral en 2013 el presidente fue
reelegido por un cuarto mandato al año
siguiente pero sus apariciones públicas
eran cada vez más escasas en un país
minado por la corrupción y la pobreza
muchos decían que ya no era apto para
gobernar pero el 10 de febrero de 2019
confirmó su candidatura y se perfiló
para un quinto mandato esa fue la gota
que colmó el vaso para los manifestantes
argelinos
decenas de miles salieron a protestar en
las calles por primera vez tras más de
20 años una movilización tenía tal
magnitud en argelia
fuertemente presionado y después de más
de cinco semanas de disputas quien fue
la cabeza del ejército ahmed gaid salah
terminó por arrebatarle el poder a quien
lo promovió abdelaziz buteflika fue
obligado de emitir